c'était une femme qui était belle et qui
avait un cœur énorme
ils étaient très amoureux tous les deux
ce 26 mars 2004 Laurent Barry vient de
découvrir le cadavre de sa femme Valérie
Barry
les gendarmes ne peuvent que constater
qu'il y a eu une scène de l'extrême
violence
la cause première du décès c'est un
traumatisme crânien
on s'attendait pas du tout à avoir une
nouvelle comme ça
tomber de
300 étages
vous savez plus trop quoi faire trop
penser quoi dire
la première pensée c'est qui a fait ça
qui a pu tué ma belle-fille
chercher elle a eu un aventure un amant
manifestement madame Barry voulait se
séparer il y avait il y avait des
rumeurs de séparation dans le couple
quelques témoins disaient
qu'effectivement
un couple se disputait régulièrement
pourquoi il a fait ça il s'est réveillé
un matin il a dit bah je vais aller tuer
ma femme
il y a pas de preuves scientifique il y
a rien quoi
ça peut pas être lui il aime trop ses
gamins pour avoir fait une chose comme
ça il serait parti oui
mais il aurait jamais fait ça
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
chronique criminels le 26 mars 2004
Valérie Barry une jeune mère de famille
est retrouvée morte dans son salon
gisant dans une mare de sang un meurtre
particulièrement barbare pour cet épouse
apparemment épanoui et sans histoire
mais alors pourquoi a-t-elle été si
sauvagement assassinée et pourquoi
Laurent son mari s'y est pris d'elle
devient-il le principal suspect
aujourd'hui pour chronique criminelle
Kevin le fils de Laurent ainsi que sa
mère revienne avec émotion sur ce drame
qui a détruit leur famille l'affaire
Laurent Barry l'histoire d'un amour
fracassé raconté par Jacques Pradel
Dijon dans le département de la
Côte-d'Or 14 février 2004 le jour de la
Saint-Valentin
parmi les clients de cette auberge
Valérie et son mari Laurent plus
amoureux que jamais
le couple affiche son bonheur pour le
plus grand plaisir de Chantal la mère de
Laurent
ils étaient très amoureux tous les deux
ma belle-fille était avec nous elle
était très gentil c'était vraiment
jamais jamais on a eu des mots plus haut
que l'autre on s'entendait vraiment bien
cela fait 6 ans que Laurent et Valérie
sont mariés et ce soir là ils s'offre
quelques heures rien qu'à eux avant de
rentrer à la maison et de retrouver
l'agitation de leur famille nombreuse
[Musique]
Valérie et Laurent ont quatre enfants
une famille recomposée Laurent le père
de famille à 35 ans il élève des poulets
et les vents dans la région Valérie sa
femme a 38 ans elle est aide-soignante
dans un hôpital
ils se sont installés dans la campagne
bourguignonne dans un hameau d'à peine
30 habitants
ici à l'anneau ils ont trouvé la maison
de leurs rêves une petite ferme à
rénover où le père de famille installé
son exploitation
[Musique]
pour Kevin le fils de Laurent c'était le
temps du bonheur
je trouve que c'était quand même la
belle vie on avait vraiment de la chance
c'est un endroit enfin moi je trouvais
chaleureux il y avait des travaux à
faire dans la maison enfin on avait
plein de projets on pouvait aussi bien
les faire du quad que les courir dans
les bois aller vers les animaux etc donc
il y avait énormément de choses à faire
on se fait on s'ennuyait pas une seconde
là-bas enfin pour moi c'était vraiment
des bons souvenirs quoi c'est clair
[Musique]
un mois après ce dîner en amoureux le 26
mars 2004 comme tous les vendredis
Laurent est sur la route c'est la
journée où il livre ses volailles à ses
clients
ce matin il est précédé de rentrer parce
qu'il a prévu de déjeuner avec sa femme
Valérie les enfants eux sont à l'école
il est environ 11h30 quand il arrive à
l'anneau
quelques minutes plus tard Laurent
couvert de sang un téléphone à la main
composé 18 un pompier décroche aussitôt
l'appel est également enregistrée on
entend Laurent Bary hurlait dans le
téléphone
dépêchez-vous ma femme est par terre je
ne sais pas ce qu'elle a
il parle de ses chiens curieusement il
dit je ne sais pas où se trouve mes
chiens
et il est arrivé quelque chose à ma
femme elle est là elle est pleine de
sang elle est couverte de sang elle a
été elle a été tuée
dépêchez-vous elle est par terre dans le
salon il y a du sang partout il y en a
plein partout j'en ai plein sur moi j'ai
soulevé sa tête elle disait rien je
trouve pas mes chiens ils sont où mes
chiens
les secours comprennent qu'il faut faire
vite 10 minutes plus tard les sirènes
transperce le silence de la campagne
pour rejoindre le petit hameau perdu au
milieu des champs
Laurent Bary les mains et le visage
ensanglantés à temps devant la maison
[Musique]
il pleure beaucoup il parle il crie
voilà il est très choqué ces propos
c'est ma femme est morte ma femme est
morte j'ai plus de femmes visiblement
Laurent Barry est en état de choc et à
l'intérieur de la ferme les gendarmes
comprennent pourquoi ils découvrent à
leur tour un spectacle d'horreur dans le
salon Valérie Barry vit dans une mare de
sang il y a des projections de sang un
petit peu partout sur les murs
[Musique]
il y a la victime allongée dans une mare
de sang habillée
un couteau de cuisine un grand couteau
de cuisine
et à proximité
c'est donc très probablement l'arme du
crime qui a été abandonné sur place par
le meurtrier
la jeune mère de famille ne présente
plus aucun signe de vie et tous les
pensées qu'elle a été assassiné
elle a quand même de très nombreuses
plaies je crois qu'elle doit avoir
quelque chose comme 12 plaies
sa tête a été à heurtée le sol à de
nombreuses reprises la cause première du
décès c'est un traumatisme crânien
le médecin des pompiers fournit aux
enquêteurs une estimation de l'heure de
la mort de Valérie Barry
lorsqu'ils
pour lui le décès d'intervenu un peu
plus d'une heure avant donc ici tu
savais à 10h30 voilà
la victime serait donc porte une heure
avant l'arrivée de Laurent Bary pour les
gendarmes tout semble indiquer que
Valérie a connu une fin extrêmement
violente sans passer d'une pièce à
l'autre certainement se battant on
découvre du sang à plusieurs endroits
on découvre des lésions de défense
notamment sur les mains on en peut en
conclure donc effectivement le meurtrier
c'est acharné sur la victime qu'elle
cherchait à se défendre et qu'il a fini
par avoir gain de cause
elle ne devait pas s'attendre à être
agressé par cette personne d'où le fait
que les enquêteurs se soient posés la
question de savoir si c'était
une connaissance
la mère de famille a été agressée dans
la cuisine et les constatations laissent
penser qu'elle s'est défendue avant de
succomber sous les coudes de son
meurtrier dans le salon
elle est habillée et le porte aucune
trace de violence sexuelle
[Musique]
dans la fermette les gendarmes
remarquent que des affaires sont
renversées pour eux ils ne fait aucun
doute que quelqu'un a fouillé à la hâte
dans les affaires du couple il n'y a pas
un désordre un désordre total dans
l'appartement en revanche effectivement
des petites choses ont bougé le sac à
main de Valérie Barry renversé
constater que il y a une commode dans le
tiroir sont retournés que la boîte à
bijoux est retournée que le
tiroir-caisse est retourné enfin voilà
comme si en fait comme s'il y avait eu
un cambriolage sur les lieux on
poursuivant leur constatation les
gendarmes remarquent que les chiens de
garde de la famille sont enfermés dans
une remise il y a deux chiens il y a un
rottweiler et un burger collie
tous les témoins disent que ces chiens
sont à l'extérieur en permanence or là
les chiens sont enfermés dans un local
attenant à la maison en leur absence
n'importe qui a donc pu pénétrer dans la
propriété
Laurent Bary lui est toujours prostré à
l'extérieur pour lui rentrer à nouveau
dans la maison semble au-dessus de ses
forces
la décision de le l'hospitaliser parce
que vraiment il va pas bien du tout à ce
moment-là il est vraiment dans un grand
état de choc
c'est dans l'unité de soutien
psychologique de l'hôpital de Dijon que
les gendarmes vont faire hospitaliser le
mari de la victime
[Musique]
ce jour-là à 60 km de l'anneau Chantal
la mère de Laurent Bary et bien loin
d'imaginer qu'un drame aussi terrible
vient de toucher sa famille
chercher un coup de fil je sais que je
me rappelle plus à quelle heure
d'un gendarme qui m'a dit que ma
belle-fille était décédée qu'il fallait
qu'on aille tout de suite
à l'hôpital général emmener des affaires
pour Laurent enfin bref donc sur le coup
comme elle avait souvent mal à la tête
j'ai pensé que c'était qu'elle avait
fait un anévrisme ou quelque chose comme
ça
donc on est parti à l'hôpital et
on a su ce qui s'était passé que 5
heures après
20 gendarme qui nous a dit que qu'elle
avait été poignardée
alors là on est tombé des nues parce que
franchement
on s'attendait pas du tout avoir une
nouvelle comme ça
[Musique]
c'est
c'est indescriptible d'ailleurs
Kevin le fils de Laurent Bary n'avait
que 12 ans à l'époque des fées mais il
n'oubliera jamais ce 26 mars 2004 vous
tombez de
300 étages quoi vous avez plus trop quoi
faire quand vous pensez quoi dire
c'est dur à gérer quoi honnêtement de
toute ma vie j'ai jamais vu mon père
déjà je l'avais jamais vu pleurer quoi
et jamais aussi abattu
je sais pas comment vous dire mais vous
voyez qu'il avait pris un train en
pleine face quoi c'était
il tremblait il était pas voilà quoi la
première pensée c'est qui a fait ça
[Musique]
qui a pu tué ma belle-fille
on est vraiment on est perdu on sait
rien on se pose des questions des tas de
questions
pourquoi comment
[Musique]
dans l'unité psychologique de l'hôpital
de Dijon 6 heures après la découverte du
corps de sa femme Laurent Bary retrouve
ses esprits en fin d'après-midi les
gendarmes l'interrogent et le mari de
Valérie leur raconte dans le détail la
journée du drame
[Musique]
une journée qui selon lui commence comme
celle de millions de Français
[Musique]
le couple se lève vers 7h30 le temps de
s'occuper de leur fille de 5 ans avant
qu'elle n'aille à l'école le vendredi
est une journée particulière pour
Laurent Bary car c'est le jour où il
effectue ses livraisons à l'un de ses
clients restaurateurs de Dijon
tous les tous les vendredis Laurent Bary
va livrer les poulets dans ce dans ce
restaurant c'est un de ses clients
habituels monsieur Barry va expliquer sa
matinée que il a fait des factures le
matin avant de partir
ce vendredi là exceptionnellement
Valérie ne travaille pas à l'hôpital la
jeune mère de famille a pris sa journée
pour s'occuper de sa petite fille Laura
et pour bricoler à la maison
elle devait poncer les poutres ils sont
en train de refaire leur maison elle
avait donc un travail de ponçage de
poutres dans le salon
d'après Laurent Bari il est aux
alentours de 9h quand il quitte la ferme
ce 26 mars 2004 l'éleveur de poulet
choisit de faire la route avec sa
voiture car sa fourgonnette ne démarre
pas Dijon est à 56 km de l'anneau
il va mettre une heure pour arriver à
Dijon et livrer donc le restaurateur
qu'il avait l'habitude de livrer
alors il arrive entre 10h et 10h15 c'est
ce qui est indiqué par le restaurateur à
ce moment-là et puis ensuite il va donc
passer quelques instants là
il reste 10 minutes un quart d'heure à
discuter et à livrer c'est ça voilà
il est donc aux alentours de 10h20 quand
Laurent Bary prend le chemin du retour
mais l'éleveurs de poulet ne va pas
directement rentrer chez lui sur la
route il s'arrête chez un ami garagiste
c'est une habitude entre les deux hommes
tous les vendredis il passe un moment
ensemble
ensuite il va s'arrêter chez un de ses
amis pour boire un café il est alors
10h30 et d'après le médecin des pompiers
c'est l'heure à laquelle Valérie Barry a
été assassiné là ils vont prendre un
café dans l'atelier discuter de choses
et d'autres notamment des problèmes
mécaniques de sa petite camionnette qui
démarre mal enfin il a du mal à démarrer
sa camionnette mais ce matin-là Laurent
Bary ne tarde pas trop car il sait que
Valérie l'attend à la maison
il quitte son ami vers 10h50 pour
prendre la route du retour
trois quarts d'heure plus tard il passe
le panneau d'entrée de l'anneau et en
arrivant chez lui il constate
immédiatement que quelque chose ne
tourne pas rond
la porte est ouverte dans le salon il
découvre le corps de sa femme couché sur
le dos elle est couverte de sang
immédiatement il la prend par la tête
mais elle ne bouge pas agar il la
recouvre avec sa parka il ne supporte
pas de la voir
la suite les gendarmes la connaissent
cinq minutes après la découverte du
corps soit à 11h35 Laurent Bary les
appelle complètement affolés
pour les enquêteurs l'urgence est de
vérifier l'emploi du temps de l'éleveur
de poulet afin d'établir s'il peut être
lié à la mort de sa femme mais il
constate que Laurent Bary a dit vrai
monsieur Barry a un alibi et puis un
alibi solide fait sa livraison donc le
restaurateur en atteste son ami
effectivement va confirmer qu'il s'est
bien arrêté chez lui pour boire un café
ah bah 10h30 ça peut pas être monsieur
Barry puisque monsieur baril entre un
livre et ses poulets pendant ce temps-là
à aucun moment il n'a donné l'impression
à ses amis à ses connaissances d'être
fébrile d'être
perturbé par quoi que ce soit c'est un
Laurent Barry comme il le voit tous les
jours depuis les années
par ailleurs les médecins de l'hôpital
examinent Laurent Bari et il ne relève
aucune trace de lutte ou de griffures
les enquêteurs les cartes de la liste
des suspects et se mettent à la
recherche d'autres pistes
[Musique]
et pour mieux comprendre ce qui a pu se
passer il se penche sur l'histoire de
cette famille et sur son entourage
[Musique]
en 1998 Laurent et Valérie se disent oui
jeunes mariés étaient fous amoureux l'un
de l'autre il est alors brancardier à la
clinique de Chenôve Valérie elle y était
soignante
[Musique]
pour eux ce mariage était le
couronnement d'un véritable coup de
foudre
je pense qu'il était très amoureux
d'elle
il dit bien ma femme c'était tout enfin
à un moment donné je crois il dit ma
femme ça a été l'explosion de tout
pour essayer d'approcher sa future
épouse avant d'oser lui dire qu'il est
amoureux d'elle il va lui déposer des
fleurs sur son pare-brise donc elle va
elle va découvrir que c'était lui cet
homme aussi amoureux ça va la toucher
valérie est divorcée et mère d'un petit
garçon Laurent lui vient de se séparer
de sa compagne avec laquelle il a eu
deux enfants Kevin et Mylène
9 mois après leur mariage une petite
fille va naître de leur union Laura
[Musique]
les voisins n'entendront plus les rires
des enfants de la famille Barry en cette
journée de mars 2004 l'obscurité vient
de s'abattre à jamais sur la petite
ferme
dès le lendemain du meurtre soit le 27
mars 2004 la presse locale s'empare de
l'affaire avec la parution du premier
article sur la mort de Valérie les
habitants du hameau prennent peur
le hameau de l'anneau est un tout petit
hameau je crois qu'il compte 4 familles
donc forcément comme souvent quand il y
a un fait divers dans un tout petit
village ça crée une espèce de psychose
ce 27 mars au matin Laurent Bary
accompagnait des gendarmes retournent
sur les lieux du drame il se rend compte
que des objets ont été dérobés
il ne retrouve plus une montre le marque
Festina alors qu'il estime il pense
qu'elle a peut-être été volée ainsi que
des je crois sur vêtements dont le
monnayeur posé sur le bureau il manque
aussi 100 euros
le préjudice semble ridicule par rapport
au crime qui vient d'être commis on a du
mal à imaginer que quelqu'un puisse tuer
pour une montre Festina et pour quelques
pièces de
d'argent
quant à l'arme du crime retrouvait près
du corps de sa femme Laurent Barry n'en
fait aucun mystère face aux gendarmes il
avoue tout de suite que ce couteau de
boucher et bien le sien
c'est un couteau un couteau très
professionnel ce couteau appartient à
Laurent Bari il dira jamais le contraire
c'est un couteau qu'il utilise pour tuer
ses volailles ou les deux PC enfin bon
dans le cadre de son métier et on ne va
pas découvrir d'empreinte digitales sur
ce sur ce couteau et un tout petit peu
d'ADN mais en quantité
insuffisante pour pouvoir en extraire un
profil génétique ce qui veut très
probablement vouloir dire que ce couteau
a été essuyé après son utilisation
[Musique]
explique qu'il a posé ce couteau sur
l'appui de la fenêtre de la cuisine en
attendant de pouvoir l'aiguiser
n'importe qui aurait donc pu s'en saisir
ce qui laisse à penser que le rôdeur ou
le le cambrioleur ce serait emparé du
couteau en progressant vers la porte
d'entrée
serait rentré avec ce couteau à la main
et ça serait servi donc pour pour tuer
pour tuer Valérie Barry
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trois jours après la mort de sa femme
Laurent Bary est autorisé à réintégrer
son logement curieusement l'unité
scientifique n'est pas encore passée et
n'a fait aucun prélèvement sur la scène
de crime ça a été figé une nuit ensuite
les scellés ont été retirés de la maison
et donc les gendarmes ont dit à mes
grands-parents qui pouvaient venir
nettoyer ce qui s'était passé on a
nettoyé tout le sang qui avait
d'une porte à une autre de la cheminée à
la porte enfin bref il y avait des
gouttes de sang partout des une grosse
flaque de sang on a tout tout nettoyé
à l'eau de javel avec mon mari
et c'est quelque chose que je ne
souhaite à personne
[Musique]
mais Laurent ne trouve pas la force de
vivre à nouveau dans cette maison il va
donc avec ses enfants aller s'installer
chez ses parents
c'est là qu'il trouve le soutien moral
dont il a besoin et c'est l'occasion
pour lui d'en dire un peu plus à son
fils
elle est dans ma chambre nous expliquer
un petit peu avec ces mots comme on peut
expliquer un enfant de 12 ans
[Musique]
il s'est passé quoi sans rentrer dans le
détail évidemment
il m'a dit donc il était rentré qu'il
avait trouvé Valérie décédé qui savait
pas ce qui s'était passé
[Musique]
et c'est tout quoi enfin il n'est pas
plus rentrer dans le détail que ça je
pense qu'il avait raison quoi
honnêtement mais bon après nous avec ce
qu'on a vu dans les journaux on savait
enfin moi je lui en ai pas parlé parce
que je savais pas trop comment aborder
le sujet forcément
donc ouais il était quand même abattu et
on a vraiment mal quoi
[Musique]
pour faire avancer leur enquête les
gendarmes se penchent aussi sur la vie
privée de Valérie Barry
chercher à la eu un aventure un amant
des relations tumultueuses avec un
voisinage enfin des choses comme ça
tous les témoignages qu'il recueillent
s'accordent pour dresser le portrait
d'une mère de famille qui n'avait aucun
ennemi c'était une femme qui était belle
et qui avait un coeur énorme madame
Barry avait semble-t-il de très bonnes
relations dans son milieu professionnel
et même en dehors alors Valérie Barry
est décrite comme une personne très
discrète très réservée
personne ne lui connaît d'ennemis
particulier
qui était quand même pleine de vie avec
un caractère assez fort quand même non
honnêtement je connaissais pas d'ennemis
quoi
pas d'amant pas d'ennemis pourtant juste
avant son décès Valérie semblait
différente elle était inquiète
trois semaines avant les faits Valérie
était
bizarre on l'avait trouvé étrange on
avait été faire une promenade dans les
bois pas très loin de chez nous
avons emmené mais on pouvait passer
éloigner etc alors qu'avant on pouvait
aller n'importe où même si on voulait
aller à 5 km de la maison dans les bois
il y avait pas de souci elle nous
lâchait pas quoi comme si en fait elle
se sentait traquée comme si elle avait
peur de quelque chose
[Musique]
les enquêteurs se focalisent sur ce
nouvel élément il se rendent à l'anneau
pour interroger les voisins de la
famille et tous les habitants du hameau
leur racontent la même histoire étrange
les jours précédant le drame ils ont
tous reçu des appels téléphoniques d'un
mystérieux interlocuteur
[Musique]
on va voir que un certain nombre de
voisins se plaignent d'avoir reçu des
coups de fil anonymes la nuit avec des
bruitages au téléphone des respirations
des choses comme ça
des bruits de respiration de
longémissement une voie âgée qui murmure
des je t'aime très lentement
les enquêteurs essaient de remonter
jusqu'à ce personnage énigmatique
parallèlement pour faire avancer
l'enquête il passe un appel à témoin
dans la presse locale
il reçoivent un témoignage intéressant
celui de la buraliste de la commune
voisine cette commerçante se souvient
d'un client au comportement très étrange
trois jours seulement après le meurtre
un homme s'était présenté à son bureau
de tabac pour acheter journal
dans un état d'excitation paye
quitte le magasin
et la buraliste va regarder ce qu'il
fait et bien il va
s'enfuir mais dans sa voiture et lire
fébrilement le journal
la buraliste s'en souvient parfaitement
ce jour-là dans l'édition du quotidien
régional un long article est consacré au
meurtre de Valérie Barry visiblement
l'inconnu était très pressé de le lire
[Musique]
cette personne présentait une morsure à
la main que la buraliste a remarqué
forcément c'était surprenant
d'après la commerçantes cette trace de
morsure était d'origine humaine et
l'homme qu'elle a vu de toute évidence
voulait se tenir informé de l'enquête
sur la mort de Valérie
pour les gendarmes c'est une piste mais
la buraliste ne parvient pas à leur
dresser un portrait robot elle n'apporte
aucun élément distinctif pour retrouver
ce personnage inquiétant
[Musique]
les jours passent puis des semaines et
des mois sans qu'aucun élément nouveau
puisse mener les gendarmes jusqu'au
meurtrier de Valérie
l'enquête est au point mort
mais un coup de théâtre va la relancer
[Musique]
six mois après le meurtre Laurent Bary
se présente dans les locaux de la
section de recherche de Dijon il a
beaucoup réfléchi à ce drame et il est
une idée sur qui aurait pu commettre ce
crime pour lui il pourrait bien s'agir
de son ancien associé
à faire des des conserves qu'il avait
commencé à faire
ses poulets
emballer les poulets et tout donc il
passait déjà à certains temps ensemble
il est venu à plusieurs reprises
travailler avec Monsieur Barry donc pour
lui filer un petit coup de main moyen
Laurent Bary explique aux enquêteurs que
cette association n'a pas duré longtemps
et surtout qu'elle se serait mal
terminée
il se trouve que c'est associé à un
moment donné faisait des avances à
Madame Barry au point qu'elle se sentait
harceler
quand il était présent elle était très
nerveuse elle partait dans une autre
pièce
et un jour Laurent Laurent l'invitait à
manger quand ils avaient fini et lui
avait demandé pourquoi
justement il avait invité à manger qu'il
avait rien à faire là elle avait peur de
lui
c'est en fin une piste sérieuse pour les
gendarmes non seulement l'ancien associé
aurait eu un comportement déplacé à
l'encontre de Valérie mais surtout son
profil pour écoler avec celui de
l'assassin
cet homme est un habitué de la maison
connaissez les chiens pouvez venir quand
ils le souhaitait il est très à l'aise
puisqu'il est venu à de nombreuses
reprises
c'est le seul qui finalement était en
capacité de gérer les chiens en dehors
de Madame Barry les enquêteurs
retrouvent leur en question il habite à
quelques kilomètres du hameau où c'est
jouer le drame et en interrogeant ils
vont aller de surprise en surprise
dans les locaux de la gendarmerie
l'interrogatoire commence les enquêteurs
passent à la loupe l'emploi du temps de
l'ancien associé de Laurent Bary en ce
qui concerne la journée tragique du 26
mars 2004 pour aller demander si la
Libye
j'étais avec ma compagne ma concubine et
puis je me suis rendu je me suivais à
telle heure puis je me suis rendu chez
mon père mais j'ai pas de témoin
personne ne m'a vu vous pouvez demander
à ma copine quand on va demander à sa
copine elle n'aura pas les mêmes heures
n'aura pas les mêmes horaires on n'aura
pas les mêmes éléments et elle ne
confirmera pas tout point la Libye de
son compagnon personne ne peut établir
où il se trouvait à ce moment-là
mais lors de son audition l'ancien
associé va retourner la situation à son
avantage scandalisée par les accusations
de Laurent Bary il va faire des
révélations qui vont bouleverser
l'enquête car d'après lui Valérie Barry
voulait divorcer
elle va essayer de charger monsieur
Barry en disant que effectivement les
relations dans le couple étaient tendu
qu'il y avait une grosse mésentente que
Monsieur Barry était quelqu'un qui avait
un tempérament à pouvoir avoir commis ce
meurtre
[Musique]
face aux gendarmes l'ancien associé des
pins un portrait de Laurent Bary pour le
moins inquiétant
selon lui l'éleveur de poulet était
obsédé par les armes blanches et par son
passé d'anciens militaire
mais il dit vous savez Laurent barise
c'était quand même quelqu'un de bizarre
c'était un ancien militaire et un jour
il s'est vanté auprès de moi
de d'avoir eu à égorger des ennemis et
il avait mi Mel geste en disant on
arrive par derrière on les prend et
craque on les égorge comme ça et ce
n'est pas tout d'après cet homme l'arme
du crime le couteau de boucher n'était
habituellement pas posé sur l'appui de
fenêtre
bien dit que le couteau qui qui a servi
à commettre l'acte normalement il est
pas dans la maison donc s'il est là
c'est très bizarre enfin voilà c'est
vraiment tout pour charger Laurent barré
les gendarmes vérifient les déclarations
de cette ancien associé et il découvre
que Laurent Barrie a bien servi pendant
trois ans dans le corps des
parachutistes blessés il a quitté
l'armée en 1990 mais impossible de
savoir s'il a eu à exécuter des ennemis
Laurent Bari n'a servi que très peu de
temps à l'étranger c'était à Djibouti
voilà qui donne un éclairage un petit
peu différent de Laurent baryse il y a
peut-être pas été très bien inspiré
dénoncer son associé lui
le témoignage de l'ancien associé
réoriente les gendarmes vers la piste
d'un drame conjugal
il découvre que juste avant le drame le
couple que forme Valérie et Laurent
seraient au bord du désastre financier
Laurent Barry n'a pas eu de chance à
peine un an après le lancement de son
exploitation la canicule de 2003
fédérale avec la chaleur tous ses
poulets sont décimés
il y a eu la sécheresse de 2003 qui a
contribué je pense à le déstabiliser par
rapport à ses projets les conditions
climatiques de vie ont fait que et bien
cela tournait plutôt à l'échec c'est un
coup dur pour Laurent Bari son
entreprise est au bord de la faillite il
ne reste plus que le petit salaire
d'aide-soignante de Valérie pour
subvenir aux besoins du foyer
et donc à la veille du meurtre la
semaine qui précède
on dit que il a les plus grandes
difficultés financières son affaire
n'est pas très viable ça marche pas
il n'y a pas que les difficultés
économiques qui détruisent le couple
Laurent et Valérie se disputent souvent
au sujet de leurs enfants respectifs les
fils de Valérie Barry étaient venus
vivre avec sa mère au domicile de
Monsieur ça se passait pas très bien
entre monsieur Barry et son beau-fils
c'est vrai qu'au difficulté économiques
s'ajoutent le fait que c'est une famille
recomposée et qui dit famille recomposer
dire rarement simplicité Valérie m'avait
téléphoné en me disant oui je vais
prendre un appartement
on va séparer
et je lui ai répondu j'ai dit Valérie
mais ton fils et son père
trois mois avant le meurtre le couple se
déchire en décembre Laurent Barry quitte
le domicile conjugal pendant une semaine
il n'hésite pas à dormir dans son camion
alors qu'à l'extérieur la température
est glaciale
[Musique]
son épouse vous laisse engager sur une
procédure de divorce et je pense qu'il
était en souffrance par rapport à ça et
puis les disputes étaient sans doute un
peu plus fréquentes elle est épuisée
Valérie Barry le couple est récent et
c'est déjà
l'empreinte des choses brisées leur
histoire il y a plus il y a plus rien
qui tourne il y a plus rien qui
fonctionne il y a plus rien qui
c'est des ruines la famille de Laurent
Barri n'est pas du tout du même avis
pour eux les difficultés du couple
appartenaient au passé car Laurent et
Valérie s'étaient réconcilié quelques
mois avant le meurtre c'est vrai qu'au
début ça n'a pas été
tout rose parce que les enfants c'est
pas toujours évident
avoir une belle mère il faut
il faut s'y faire et puis partir du mois
de janvier tout était devenu normal oui
songs
comme dans tous les couples ils étaient
mariés depuis 7 ans 7 ans forcément on
se pose des questions etc enfin je veux
dire ils avaient quand même des projets
quoi c'était ils ont parlé de séparation
je pense c'était enfin voilà comme quand
on se dispute ouais ben je m'en vais et
puis des bruits toi quoi parce que pour
la Saint-Valentin ils ont fait quelque
chose ils ont été au restaurant l'hôtel
etc donc un couple qui va se séparer je
doute vraiment qu'il fasse ça c'est tout
c'est pour moi je sais qu'il voulait
qu'il voulait pas se séparer quoi c'est
clair
un mois avant le meurtre le jour de la
Saint-Valentin Laurent et Valérie
donnent l'image d'un couple qui s'est
retrouvé mais pour les gendarmes ce
dîner en amoureux n'est pas une preuve
suffisante pour eux Laurent Bary devient
le suspect numéro
un an et demi s'est écoulé depuis le
meurtre en octobre 2005 les enquêteurs
sont toujours à la recherche de preuves
pour étayer leur convictions afin de
prouver la culpabilité de Laurent Bary
il reprenne tout à zéro et les gendarmes
découvrent que quelque chose l'oreille
chappé depuis le début ma femme est
morte où sont mes chiens
les gendarmes vont réécouter les
enregistrements l'appel au secours et
remarquer et faire une déduction de
gendarmes que Laurent Bailly a dit mais
où sont mes chiens où sont mes chiens
ils entendent en arrière-plan des
aboiements lointains
il est 11h35 le 26 mars donc on est
vraiment à quelques minutes de la
découverte du corps et déjà il y a un
truc qui cloche d'après les gendarmes
les aboiements de l'enregistrement
prouveraient que les chiens de Laurent
Barrie étaient à ce moment-là à côté de
lui et qui les aurait enfermés lui-même
pour faire croire qu'un cambrioleur
pouvait entrer et un autre élément
conforte les enquêteurs dans leur doute
à l'encontre du mari il réexamine la
toute première déclaration que Laurent
Bary leur avait faite sur son emploi du
temps en relisant le PV d'audition il
remarque que l'agriculteur a indiqué
avoir fait ses factures le matin du
crime avant de prendre la route mais en
examinant l'historique de son ordinateur
les enquêteurs remarquent qu'il n'a pas
été allumé ce matin là
a déclaré avoir fait ses factures le
matin avant de partir et il s'avère que
les gendarmes vont découvrir que en fait
ces factures et les a faites la veille
donc encore une fois on va partir du
principe que Monsieur bariment et que
s'il manque c'est qu'il a des choses à
cacher pour les gendarmes il n'y a pas
que les fausses déclarations de Laurent
Bary qu'il incrimine il y a aussi un
rapport d'experts sur des chaussons
retrouvés dans sa voiture 11 jours après
le meurtre et il est accablant pour
l'éleveur de poulet on va donc trouver
un petit peu de sang qui serait le sang
de Madame Barry sous la semelle
pour eux ça va conforter la thèse de la
culpabilité de Laurent Marie ils vont
partir du principe que il y a du sens
sous la semelle de ce chausson parce que
c'est lui qui a tué sa femme
dans les locaux de la section de
recherche les enquêteurs accumulent les
éléments à charge contre Laurent Bary
mais il leur reste un problème son alibi
le médecin des pompiers présent sur les
lieux le jour du crime stipulé que
Valérie était morte à 10h30 heure à
laquelle son mari était à Dijon
mais l'autopsie du corps de Valérie va
bousculer cette certitude le médecin
légiste donne un créneau horaire plus
large et moins précis que le médecin des
pompiers selon lui le décès aurait pu
intervenir entre 9h45 et 11h30 Valérie
peut donc avoir été tué plutôt et pour
les enquêteurs cela change tout
[Musique]
le rapport du médecin légiste va
effectivement donner un tournant
l'enquête dans la mesure où on va
ensuite dire que matériellement parlant
monsieur Marie pouvait être sur les
lieux du crime au moment du meurtre le
souci c'est l'heure éventuelle de départ
de Laurent Barry
[Musique]
l'éleveur serait-il parti de chez lui
entre 9h20 et 9h40 et non 9 heures comme
il l'avait indiqué aux enquêteurs lors
de sa première déposition les gendarmes
de la section de recherche de Dijon vont
refaire le trajet afin de le chronomètre
et ils vont mettre beaucoup moins de
temps que ce qu'avait indiqué le Robin
présenté par les gendarmes indiquait 20
minutes de moins que le temps indiqué
par Monsieur Barry
les gendarmes ils vont considérer que de
l'anneau jusqu'au restaurant où on va se
rendre monsieur barré il faut 39 minutes
39 minutes au lieu d'une heure comme
l'indiqué Laurent
plus aucun doute aux enquêteurs il
aurait pu avoir le temps de tuer sa
femme avant de prendre la route
pour les gendarmes le scénario du
meurtre se met en place
le vendredi 26 mars 2004 dans la matinée
lors d'une dispute qui aurait dégénéré
Laurent Barry aurait tué sa femme puis
il aurait pris soin d'essuyer l'arme du
crime avant d'aller se nettoyer
il aurait ensuite mis ses vêtements
tâchés de sang dans un sac et emporter
avec lui ses chaussons
sur la route il se serait débarrassé de
ses affaires mais dans la précipitation
il aurait oublié ses pantoufles une
erreur dans un parcours presque sans
faute c'est en tout cas la conviction
des enquêteurs
le gendarme de la section de recherche
de Dijon ont toutes les pièces du puzzle
pour eux il n'y a plus qu'un seul visage
sur celui du meurtrier présumé de
Valérie celui de son mari
[Musique]
le 17 janvier 2006 après deux ans
d'enquête les gendarmes décident de
placer Laurent Bary en garde à vue
ils sont bien déterminés à obtenir ces
aveux
mais Laurent Barry tient bon le jour du
meurtre il réaffirme qu'il n'était pas
présent il nie avec véhémence être le
meurtrier de sa femme mais les gendarmes
ne le croient pas
en garde à vue il prend l'attitude du
silence en fait de la de il nie les
faits il sent que les doses resserre il
se dit que c'est le les dernières
complications avant que soit les choses
basculent soit il soit définitivement
innocenté
parallèlement à la garde à vue les
enquêteurs organisent une ultime
perquisition chez les parents du suspect
c'est là qu'il habite depuis deux ans
en fouillant dans ses affaires les
gendarmes vont retrouver la montre
Festina que Laurent Bary avait déclaré
volé cette découverte va les conforter
dans l'idée que le suspect ne leur dit
pas toute la vérité
[Musique]
donc ils vont eux tout de suite se
saisir de cela pour dire donc vous avez
simulé vous avez simulé un faux
cambriolage puisque cette montre vous ne
l'aviez pas perdu et là évidemment c'est
un grand moment de solitude parce que
Laurent Bary là je pense qu'il a compris
que les choses basculaient dans le
mauvais sens pour lui
deux ans après le meurtre de sa femme
est pressé par les questions des
gendarmes Laurent Bary finit par
reconnaître qu'il a menti
c'est à la 29e heure de garde à vue
que Laurent Bary va consentir annuaire
reconnaître et qu'il a fait ce simulacre
de cambriolage
poussé dans ses derniers retranchements
Laurent Barry explique avoir simulé une
scène de cambriolage parce qu'il avait
eu peur d'être accusé du meurtre de sa
femme au gendarmes il raconte tout il a
vidé les tiroirs de la commode il a
renversé les affaires et surtout il a
caché sa montre Festina
il finira par avouer que effectivement
il a organisé ce faux cambriolage parce
qu'il avait peur finalement d'être
suspecté mais quand on est totalement
innocent ça vient pas forcément à l'idée
d'essayer de se dédouaner en maquillant
un crime
ne s'arrête pas là il va aussi
reconnaître du goût des lèvres que c'est
lui qui a enfermé les chiens les
explications par rapport à son chien à
ses chiens seront confuses et quelque
part il voudra expliquer l'inexplicable
ce qui n'aura fait que rajouter
au doute au doute qui pèsent après il
savait plus très bien si c'était comme
ils allaient enfermer parce qu'il a
jeunesse si c'était elle qui lui avait
demandé parce que souvent elle aimait
pas être dérangée par les chiens qui
aboyaient dans la cour elle voulait pas
les avoir dans la maison enfin pendant
ces dernières heures de garde à vue
Laurent Bary explique cette disputée
avec sa femme ce matin-là le matin avant
de partir Laurent barré c'est lui qui
l'indique il y a pas de témoin donc il
n'était pas obligé de le dire mais il
dit oui on a une petite dispute le matin
mais ça avait un trait au ponçage des
poutres
pour les gendarmes le motif de la
disputes ne serait pas celui avancé par
le mari d'après eux ce matin-là Valérie
lui aurait dit une dernière fois qu'elle
voulait le quitter
c'était vraiment quelque chose qui ne
pouvait pas envisager de se séparer il
fallait la détruire
[Musique]
on peut donc imaginer rétrospectivement
que Laurent Barry
à tuer sa femme
qu'il a maquillée ce crime
[Musique]
qu'il enfermait les chiens
et ensuite ils montent à Dijon comme si
de rien n'était et c'est seulement à son
retour qu'il donne l'alerte
[Musique]
en garde à vue Laurent Bary n'ira
toujours être le meurtrier de son épouse
le 17 février 2006 soit presque deux ans
après la mort de sa femme il est mis en
examen pour homicide volontaire et il
est écroué à la maison d'arrêt de Dijon
pour sa famille c'est incarcération est
un véritable traumatisme pourquoi il a
fait ça il s'est réveillé un matin il a
dit bah je vais aller sur ma femme il y
a pas de preuves scientifique il y a
rien quoi en dossier non non ça peut pas
être lui il aime trop ses gamins pour
avoir fait une chose comme ça il serait
parti oui
mais il aurait jamais fait ça des
preuves de son innocence il y a que ça
quoi par contre de sa culpabilité
j'aimerais bien qu'on trouve une tout
l'enjeu du procès des 6 à venir et de
savoir si Laurent Barry est un coupable
idéal ou un meurtrier manipulateur
[Musique]
le procès de Laurent Barri s'ouvre trois
ans plus tard en octobre 2009 entre
temps ses avocats ont obtenu sa
libération conditionnelle c'est donc
libre qu'il comparait une équipe de
télévision l'avait rencontré à ce
moment-là
[Musique]
je suis assez nerveux et voilà
9 jurés vont devoir se prononcer sur la
culpabilité de Laurent Bary et leur
tâche s'avère complexe puisque dans ce
dossier il n'y a qu'un élément tangible
le chausson de Laurent Barry légèrement
taché du sang de sa femme les ont été
retrouvés donc on joue après dans la
voiture
si j'avais été l'auteur des feuilles je
pense que j'aurais été assez intelligent
pour retirer les chaussons alors que la
gendarmerie m'avait appelé la veille
pour me dire votre voiture je pense
qu'il y a quand même un minimum mais les
délégations de Laurent Bari passe mal
car dans le box il ne trouve pas ces
mots et n'a pas l'attitude que les jurés
attendent d'aninnocent
il était vraiment renfermé
il pleurait quand même assez souvent
quand on évoquait Valérie etc donc je
pense que ça va pas jouer en sa faveur
de rester vraiment il était vraiment
enfermé un visage fermé il avait l'air
froid etc
je pense qu'à ce moment là je me suis
barrée il passe pas forcément très bien
appeler à la barre le médecin légiste
donne le coup de grâce à l'accusé car il
revient sur ses conclusions concernant
l'heure de la mort de Valérie on dit que
ça pouvait aller jusqu'à 9h voir 8h30 et
jusqu'à 11h30 quoi donc en gros il y a
même plus d'heures précises l'idée c'est
quoi il y a une fourchette qui moins de
paraît vraiment trop large quoi c'est
simplement improbable impossible et
scandaleux c'est à dire qu'on voulait
absolument avoir la peau on voulait
absolument faire condamner
la personne accusée Laurent baffe
pour la défense le chronométrage réalisé
par les gendarmes n'est pas réaliste
impossible je vous défie de le faire
honnêtement puis n'importe qui ou alors
vous le faites avec une voiture de
gendarmerie avec les gyrophares et à 160
tout le long quoi alors où était le mari
à l'heure du crime c'est à cette
question que le jury va devoir répondre
[Musique]
le 23 octobre 2009 après avoir délibéré
pendant plus de 4 heures la cour
reconnait Laurent Barry coupable du
meurtre de sa femme il est condamné à 20
ans de prison
je me suis dit
mon fils est perdu
[Musique]
vous dites 20 ans quoi je les avais même
pas à l'époque que j'avais 18 ans
je me disais
parce que j'arrivais pas à parler à ce
procès
parce que j'ai pas réussi à dire que je
voulais dire
[Musique]
il faut toujours
un an plus tard la peine de Laurent
Barry est confirmée en appel aujourd'hui
derrière les barreaux il clament
toujours son innocence pour le meurtre
de sa femme
[Musique]